What I want to do
in this video is
go over what I think is one
of the more intuitive ways
to sort a list.
It's how I would probably sort
it, if I had to do it manually.
But I want to make it clear, it
is not the most efficient way
to sort a list.
I think it's a good starting
point to getting warmed up
with sorting lists.
It's called insertion_sort.
And I'm going to give
a graphical description
of the algorithm
for insertion_sort.
And just so you
know what, algorithm
sounds like a very fancy
word, but an algorithm
is really just a way of sorting
it, or a process for doing it,
or a method for doing it.
A program is a specific
implementation of an algorithm,
or it can be a specific
implementation of an algorithm.
Once I have a general algorithm,
I could implement it in Python.
I could implement it in C. I
could implement it in Java.
Those are specific programs.
But they'd all be implementing
the same way of doing the sort.
And that's what I'm
describing here,
the insertion_sort algorithm.
So let's just start
with a simple example.
Let's say that I have a list.
Let's say I have a Python
list, because we're
going to be working
in Python for this.
And that list is, let's
say, it is 7, 3, 1, 2, 4, 6.
And so the way that
we do insertion_sort
is you go element by element.
And then you compare it
to the elements before it.
And then you look for the
first element before it
that it is actually less than.
And then you just stick
it right over there.
So let me show you
what I'm talking about.
So you could start with the
7, the 0-th element over here.
But when you start
with a 0-th element,
you're like, hey,
wait, there's nothing
before it to compare it to.
So it really doesn't make sense
to start with the 0-th element.
So really, if you were to
implement this algorithm,
you'll start it with
the third element.
Or sorry, you'll start it with--
if this is the 0-th element,
you'd start it with the first
element right over here.
If this is 0-th, this is first.
I know this can be a
little confusing when
you refer to this as
the first element.
But this one's the 0-th.
So you start with this 3 here.
And then you start comparing
it to all of the elements
before it.
And as soon as you find an
element that 3 is less than,
you stick it in that
part of the list.
So what you do is you
say, OK, is 3 less than 7?
Well, yeah, it is less than 7.
So what you want to do is you
want to shift 7 where the 3 is.
So let me put it out here.
So we're trying to compare 3 to
everything before it right now.
So you say, OK,
is 3 less than 7?
Yeah, it is less than 7.
So let's put the
7 where the 3 is.
And let's put the 3 where
the 7 is, especially
because there's nothing
left to compare the 3 to.
There's no elements
before the 0-th element,
so let's just stick
the 3 right over there.
And so our list now
looks like this.
Our list now looks like
3, 7, 1, 2, 4, and 6.
And one thing you'll
find interesting,
or something to
pay attention to,
is as we build this list--
so the 0-th element is now
definitely less than
the first element.
And everything up to and
including the first element
is now sorted.
And that will be true, as
we keep going through this.
As we keep going through higher
and higher indexes, up to
and including that
index after we've done
that pass will be sorted.
And I'll try to point
that out as we go along.
So we did the first index.
So we already did
the first index.
Now we can move on to
the second element,
which is this 1 over here.
And so you take that 1.
I'll put it on the
side right over here.
You take that 1 and you compare
it to each of the elements
before it.
OK, is 1 less than 7?
Sure, 1 is less than 7.
So let's stick the
7 where the 1 is.
And then you could
just keep comparing,
or you could just stick
the 1 where the 7 is.
And then you would say,
OK, is 1 less than 3?
Well, yeah, sure.
It's less than 3.
So let's stick the
3 where the 1 is.
And let's put the
1 where the 3 is.
So what is our list now?
Our list now is going to look
like 1, 1, 3, 7, 2, 4, 6.
So notice, after we've
gotten to the n-th index-- so
in this case, this
was the index of 2
where that 1 was right
over there-- everything up
to and including
that index is sorted.
This part right here is sorted.
Other things are going to
be thrown in here, probably,
as we go on.
But so far, this part is sorted.
So you can see by the time we
get to the end of this list,
everything is
going to be sorted.
So let's now go
to the next index,
or the next item in the list.
And that is this 2 over here.
And so we compare
the 2 to the 7.
2 is definitely less
than the 7, so let's put
the 7 where the 2 is, and
let's put the 2 where the 7 is.
Now you compare the 2 to the 3.
2 is less than 3.
So let's put the 3 where
the 2 is, and let's
put the 2 where the 3 is.
Then compare 2 to 1.
Is 2 less than 1?
No, it is not less than 1, so we
don't have to do anything else.
We don't have to keep
going to the left.
And so now, after this
pass-- in this pass,
we were comparing this 2 item
to everything before that.
So after this pass, our
list looks like this.
Our list looks like
1, 2, 3, 7, 4, 6.
And notice everything up to
and including the third item,
so 0-th 1 2, third
item, is now sorted.
And now we're ready to look at
the next element in the list.
And one thing I
want to make clear,
when you actually
implement it, there's
a couple of ways to do it.
So in this example, we
said, hey, 2 is less than 7.
We had the 7 replace where
the 2 is, which you should do.
And then we had the 2
replace where the 7 is.
But the reality is you
can keep going down,
until you find a good
place to put the 2,
and shifting everything
to the right as you do it,
and then putting the 2 in.
Although this way, it's a little
bit easier to keep track of.
And well, maybe we'll
explore different ways
to do it when we actually
implement the algorithm.
Anyway, let's look at this 4.
Same exact idea.
4 is less than 7,
so let's put the 7
where the 4 is and put
the 4 where the 7 is.
Is 4 less than 3?
No, it's not less
than 3, so we stop.
We're done.
Now everything up to and
including the fourth item
in this list, 0, 1, 2,
3, 4, is now sorted.
And now our list
looks like-- let
me scroll down a little bit--
now our list looks like this.
Let me write it down.
It is 1, 2, 3, 4, 7, and then 6.
And now we can go to this
last element in the list.
This is the 6 that
we're now comparing.
Actually, the last
time we did this,
it was a 4 that we cared about.
But now we care about the 6.
Is 6 less than 7?
Sure, it is.
So let's put 7 where the 6 is.
Let's put a 6 where the 7 is.
Is 6 less than 4?
No, it's not.
And so we stop, because
we know that this
is going to be sorted.
If we went any
further, we're just
going to get elements that
are less than or equal to 4.
So we are done.
We have sorted this list.
The sorted list is now
1, 2, 3, 4, 6, and 7.
In the next video,
I'm actually going
to try to implement this
algorithm that I just
described.
And I'm going to implement it
in a simple Python function.